des brasiers gourmands dans l'Ouest
canadien des communautés balafrées par
Fiona dans l'est du pays sans compter
toutes les catastrophes naturelles dans
le monde qui resteront dans les annales
de 2022
des événements marquants potentiellement
exacerbés par les effets des changements
climatiques mais qui n'ont visiblement
pas su convaincre les 183 États à
s'engager à la hauteur de la crise selon
un nouveau rapport de l'ONU on a quand
même vu un léger progrès par rapport à
ce qu'on avait l'année passée donc il y
a eu quand même un changement de 3%.
mais c'est pas ça que la science exhi le
rapport de l'ONU indique que les
engagements actuels des pays feront
augmenter les émissions de 10,6% d'ici
2030 par rapport au niveau de 2010
alors qu'on devrait plutôt les réduire
de 40% d'ici 2030 afin de limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
Celsius
planète pourtant au terme de la cop22
les pays s'étaient engagés à rehausser
leur cible climatique avant la cop27 en
Égypte le Canada fait partie de ceux qui
n'ont pas respecté leurs promesses le
Canada a échoué le premier test avant
que la cop27 commence le premier test
était de présenter un plan climat
renforcé comme le Canada c'était engagé
de les faire à Glasgow
il y a un an les données montrent que
les émissions projetées continueraient
d'augmenter au-delà de 2030 si les
nouvelles données démontrent que les
émissions n'augmentent plus après 2030
elle n'affiche toujours pas une tendance
à la baisse rapide que la science juge
nécessaire
le Canada lui s'est doté d'un plan
climatique incluant un cadre législatif
40 % de réduction or selon les experts
le pays ne se donne pas les moyens de
ses ambitions et se gardent bien de
fournir des échéanciers de plus
Ottawa manquerait transparence on sait
pas par exemple comment le le la
limitation des émissions du secteur
pétrolier et gazier comment est-ce que
ça va contribuer par exemple à aider le
gouvernement du Canada a atteindre les
objectifs du pays les rapports
accablants s'accumulent sans qu'on sache
vraiment quels sont les plans concrets
pour atteindre les cibles promises alors
que 2030 et à nos portes et que les
phénomènes climatiques nous rappellent
de plus en plus souvent se laisser aller
ici Elisa Serey Radio-Canada MONT réal